a lot of people are most likely never
going to meet him yeah so I feel like we
all got a chance to kind of yeah that's
a good good idea Brittany so Brittany
why don't you speak
I felt like he was he was really polite
in person I didn't expect him to be like
you said so smiley
um very warm and I will say that I do
feel like he is very is very pretty
grounded he is fair
um there were just things obviously I
just don't agree with about the being
agreeable to the point of where it's not
your own identity but I also understood
where he was coming from
um I understood the perspective I don't
agree but no I felt like he was like so
different in person and I feel like
that's why you can't really judge people
based on that he was just different I
don't know am I am I tripping did you
guys feel that way
but 45 seconds yeah
actually I
I remember when he got canceled I said
the only problem with this guy is the
fact that he's exposing certain truths
and not providing a solution to those
who are suffering from it that's it
other than that listen yeah he's better
looking in person
yes
yes I I I tried to hate on him he's bad
looking person he's smiling his friend
he's got high energy he's a good
Sagittarius sunshine in human form he's
actually quite cool I liked him yes
yeah I feel like it was a straight
talker and you know what I I really rate
the way he speaks he really knows how to
speak like it will add context and then
it'll make his point I think it takes a
lot of talent to do that and you can
tell he's been doing it for a long time
so I have to respect that in him
obviously I didn't agree completely with
a lot of stuff you were saying because I
I feel like he was a bit one-sided when
I was talking about what men wants and
he wasn't really talking about how to
make women happy but I I appreciated
that he was also given us a perspective
of a lot of men out there so I did
appreciate that but I I just wish we
could like explore more about what women
want really
I just think that Society I was always
talking about what women want is that
the timer I just feel like society's
always talking about women what women
want and whenever whenever we talk about
what men might want like we always need
to have a response and it's like why
can't we just let the men talk for a
second because like we we there's Steve
Harvey like talks about what women want
all the time there's a million different
shows
um as for Andrew Tate
I was actually so nervous I don't know
why like I was
good job what I was too I was busy
I think I was I kind of think I was a
little quieter because I was like I'm
just like nervous I don't know why but
he was so nice um it was really nice if
a lot of people don't know we were
supposed to go to do all of us we're
supposed to go to Dubai uh my passport
expires within six months so we couldn't
actually like get in I couldn't get in
the country uh so he actually came to us
which I thought was really like kind of
him to come yeah like fly all the way
here but yeah he was really nice
um I was really nervous but overall I
already liked him before I didn't like
him the first time I saw him if you see
my very first reaction to him I was
actually mean because he had a cheating
party
and I was like what is this cheating
party and it's like he would invite all
his girlfriends over at the same time
where like all the girls he would cheat
with and like they would just go to the
same place and it was kind of fun but I
was like what why would you do that but
I didn't understand what but now that I
understand his world view a little bit
more I was like oh well that's why yeah
he was very
I from what the stuff he was saying like
beforehand from uh watching Kevin
Samuels uh with pearl it it opened up
um my view on like actually listening to
people or listening to what these men
are saying instead of just taking a
cliff and taking for how these people
are clipping it and wanting to get their
agenda across but actually listening to
him and I like sat down and like
actually listened to some of the stuff
that he said beforehand so I was like he
the what he is saying
is not crazy it's the way he's saying it
and people a lot I would say people and
a lot of women don't like the way that
he is saying it because it's very like
raw like this is it this is how I'm
gonna say and I don't care if you don't
like the way I'm saying it I'ma say it
this way and I feel like a lot of people
don't like it like that but it's like if
you get past what he's like how he's
saying it and listen to actually what he
is saying is like oh okay it's not as
outrageous as people make it out to be
but yeah that's why I actually purposely
didn't really go and look at his content
because I was like I want to see who he
actually is and what his energy is
actually saying because I understand the
same way that people say oh you could
wait to do edited this way to make me
look worse than that it's the same way
that happens to him and realistically he
was way more balanced and actually a lot
more kind of
calming in his presence than what he
actually seems online I'm not gonna lie
he spoke since there was a lot of
balance in what he said and you know I
know people expecting me to Clash with
him and I didn't he was cool I liked him
it's funny he had to build Phantom
result with his Clementines and stuff
he's just I think the only thing I
didn't agree with was like him talking
about a man will cheat like women are
delusional like I think that's not a
good message
too they will if they have like the okay
okay I'll give you an example even a
good man would have a hard time being in
Tiger Woods positions having a position
having a Bus full of models waiting for
him that are trying to [ __ ] him every
single day it's like even a good like my
my dad I'll give you he's top one
percent doesn't cheat but my dad doesn't
have social media and he doesn't have
beautiful models waiting for him every
day after work I think that would be
hard for even a good man yeah to say no
to like even my dad if he was in a
position where beautiful women are
trying to do that every single day
that's hard that's really hard for a guy
get approached as well in fact women
true true true true but it's not usually
it's not usually by men you want it
would I would also argue I would also
argue that it would be hard for a woman
to stay faithful if every day she was
approached by high value men that's true
so but yeah like you've been in that
position it's yeah it's if every day
you're getting messages from like the
top men in society
I I think that's hard for women to turn
down we're hypergamous
so it's not really about the quantity of
men that approach you it's the quality
just morally I think everybody knows
that cheating is wrong you know like Tay
even said it himself when a woman cheats
on a man the pain that he feels so they
know it's wrong innately but they think
that they have that path to do it
because I'm a man I'm a high value man
and it's like do you know that pain that
you felt she feels that it's yeah no I
and I I agree with you I've I've been
cheated on it was really hard but but at
the end of the day it's just not the
same because like at the end of the day
like I could get past it because I was
like you know what it was just a random
it wasn't like he wasn't in love with
her but like the way we would feel if a
man was in love with someone else that's
how men feel about us cheating on them
sexually like there's just uh do you
think it's because there's just like uh
how do I want to say this do you think
it's because men are weaker in that
department to where it's like oh you
can't even I can't believe you had sex
with guys before you even met me because
that's my [ __ ] you know what I mean
like I almost feel like it's because
there's such a gap in where women really
are and where men are emotionally and
mentally I as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible